[Music]  so you're nervous normal yeah I mean  I've been in this town in a minute his  feet and McIntyre brings back a lot of  bad memories people that haven't seen me  in a couple years are going to be  shocked the cool thing about it is you  have a good body you have a new attitude  and well like you add to it you got  we're here now look at the house like  they have totally change this like what  am I doing here that's the house that I  used to live in with the kids what a lot  of was little yeah there did a lot of  work to the house it looks better but  it's still the same damn house that  house doesn't serve good memories either  this is gonna be awesome  let's rock and roll baby I know I look  good but I am NOT nervous because it's  be the first policy issue ever since the  surgery  and I don't know what he's gonna think  we are ready come on through I'm a mom  I'm ravenous let's get ready to shot in  the world come on  [Music]  [Music]